they've accepted that half the country
will be allowed to do it and they're
like yay we won this one instead a real
victory would have been the supreme
court coming out and being like
all human life has constitutional
protections whether they're in the womb
or out therefore taking the life is a
violation of the constitution that would
have been a much better victory agreed
if a if if a human has a response to
life liberty pursuit of happiness what
then then the actual conservative
position would be for the supreme court
to come out and say that's right a a
human unborn baby is still a human and
it would be a violation of the law and
the constitution to end its life or to
grant the right to do so ergo the
supreme court would have said nationwide
it actually this actually makes more
sense
the constitution granting protection to
women to get abortions makes less sense
than the constitution granting rights to
a human being not to be killed yeah
however the conservative court didn't
even rule that they said leave us out of
it and the left is saying the
republicans are extremists no the left
are the extremists the republicans are
happy to accept a moderate victory
meaning we'll take what we can get in
our red states and you do your thing
whereas the left says we want total
domination nationwide and that's that's
that's what i was saying to begin with
that roe v wade and its inception was
illegitimate and that it they're making
it seem like it being overturned as a
far-right
a far-right policy position when really
it's the lukewarm moderate position
agreed and so therefore mitch mcconnell
actually shouldn't get the same credit
that
that that he may get in in in our view
but
the the the
the point that i think needs to be
driven home about
abortion
is that when a society loses the
sanctity of life
you can't have a precept of human rights
and civil rights legitimately totally
agree
based on the slaughter of the native
population they're all humans they were
all humans but they didn't act like they
were true no and that and that was a
that was um protestant christians taking
the lord's name in vain it's not an
indictment of god and it's not an
indictment of america it's an indictment
of those
few men who chose to use the lord's name
in that way at that time but it still
doesn't change the universal truth about
life whether it be native whether it be
american unborn today or whether it be
blacks during slavery
the precept of human rights and civil
rights has to be dependent on a sanctity
of life if you don't have the sanctity
of life it doesn't only allow you to
justify killing a
human fetus which is is an infowar of
biblical proportions but it also allows
you to kill faceless people by double
tap drone strikes in afghanistan yeah so
yeah so i want to i want to
jump on that first i want to respond to
what tim said because i think you make a
great point
yeah i'm going to respond hold on so so
i don't think that's entirely fair i
agree with your assessment completely
that the conservative pro-life position
is and should be that abortion must be
illegal nationwide i still think it's
it's perfectly reasonable to say thank
goodness that it can be restricted in
some places now we haven't gone all the
way with it this is not the end
yeah and uh my point is just
republicans consistently fight for the
moderate exact form yeah the compromise
yeah and i would agree with that i think
that
leaving it up to the states is
ultimately the moderate position and i
don't think it makes a whole lot of
sense i have a question for you and for
conservatives
when do you think
when at what point does a person gain
constitutional rights uh i would say the
moment of fertilization
yeah you're a human being at that point
what do you think
yeah i would say the conception
what are you thinking uh when they get a
birth certificate why because that's
american citizens of american human
rights if slaves didn't have birth
certificates yeah they didn't have those
same human rights they they were granted
under the 14th amendment well eventually
they got them through after the 14th
amendment like there's no amendment that
says that a unborn fetus has human
rights but that but
i don't know if that's relevant so
you're asking me what i think morally it
should be not yeah he's asking for your
like uh preachers well no no no no no
that's fine that's why i accept your
answer when they get a birth certificate
when they're born so my question is just
like why when they're born you know like
why is that the case because um yeah why
when they're when they're that's when
they start contributing to society
i i don't think so i think yeah that's a
rat scene the problem the problem with
with it with that viewpoint
is
it's a radical materialist mentality
and what you're basically saying is that
your only value as a human being
is your contribution to society and and
that is a that is a predicate for the
fourth industrial revolution whether
people want to consider it or not this
whole abortion argument is really a
predicate for the fourth industrial
revolution to be able to other
human beings based on their level of
productivity and justify killing them by
food whether it be big pharma maybe a
pandemic
whatever the nuclear war
health freedom climate whatever it is
the ability to
judge and rule somebody based on what
they contribute to society solely as the
the anchor of their human rights or the
fundamental claim of human rights
is is just about as anti-human as you
can get i don't know because what if
they start tapping people's brains with
neural net reading minds doing
pre-thought crime and they do it to
babies in the womb and they're like that
baby had an illegal thought when it was
two months old it's going to be it's now
arrested
there'll be no neural net if i'm in
congress that's a heresy that's a heresy
to begin with so let's
let me pull up this story we have from
timcast.com
anna navarro doubles down on comments
about aborting special needs babies
she went on to say that she has a she
says quote i have a brother who's 57 and
has the mental and motor skills of a
one-year-old and i know what that means
financially emotionally physically for a
family i have a step granddaughter who
was born with down syndrome and you know
what it's very difficult in florida to
get services
it is not as easy as it sounds on paper
i've got another i've got a step
grandson who's very autistic
this was her example for why there needs
to be abortion effectively saying that
all of these people should be dead all
people have disabilities that's a
psychotic thing to say so so ian just a
moment ago you mentioned that
you know when a person is born is when
they gain constitutional rights my
question is
does the 57 year old man with the motor
skills of a one-year-old have
constitutional rights yeah do you think
he does yeah what about a baby born with
no brain yeah does that cause it has a
name and a birth certificate but a baby
with a full functioning brain that
functions more so than a born baby that
has no brain
the unborn like so let's say that says
two women and they and they're both
sitting there both equally as pregnant
as each other
and one baby is born
and the other was not but they're they
were fertilized the exact same time the
one still in the womb has a fully
functioning brain and the one outside of
the womb has no brain just a just a
cerebellum so it's basic motor functions
you think the one without a brain does
have constitutional rights and the one
in the womb does not yes
so
then killing the one in the womb is fine
it's it's more ethical than killing the
living human yeah so
i accept your answer but i don't
understand it no i do it
and i'm and
i don't say this to be disparaging at
all because you're my boy i like you
here it comes no i do i i like you um
but this is that whole
sapiens uh noah yuval harari school of
thought
is that um
reality can only be measured by
suffering
right
and like that's the ultimate form of
measurement of of reality yeah and so
the the suffering argument is
whatever we can do to eliminate
suffering to have to confront suffering
to have to confront anxiety and despair
whatever we can do to eliminate having
to go through that process that is
painful we'll do that and then we can
justify doing it to kids because most
likely if they're born into some
patriarchal white supremacy society then
they'll suffer
and my point is that
who do we think actually ends up dead in
those scenarios from these
white yuppy snowflake milk toasts
uniparty globalists establishment
politicians black people brown people
the numbers suggest that i i have a
thought experiment for you ian
so all right let's let's see right here
you've got two women they both conceived
they both had a baby conceived in them
at the exact same moments
one baby has no brain and is born and
the other baby has a brain totally
functioning completely average unborn
and you said that you think the one that
was born but doesn't have a brain has
more constitutional rights or does have
constitutional rights and the one unborn
doesn't
right yeah i think i don't know what the
law is about like a brain dead person
being born if the parent has the right
to kill it
you believe that the baby that was born
even with no brain has constitutional
rights and the unborn has like one's
born prematurely with no brain no
they're both they're both nine months
gestation but one was born and the other
wasn't born yet because there's there's
variation so you're gonna give the
rights to the born okay so thought
experiment a mad scientist comes in the
room and goes
and he fires a growth ray at the other
one now she's 70 feet tall but the
babies stay the same size her womb is
now a giant open room and they bring in
a tv and a table and the baby's still
there and then someone raises the baby
but still in the womb
the baby learns to read and write does
it still does it have constitutional
rights yet
no not by modern day law but by your by
your opinion should it with growth raise
um no
i have to rewrite the law my point is
i'm trying to understand why you don't
think that baby has any rights if the
womb became as big as a skyscraper due
to a mad scientist an alien blast i'm
just like ah she turns into a building
and the baby is still technically in the
womb but it's massive now and people
walk inside and they're teaching it math
and reading and it's and it's aging and
eating food you it has no rights
still in the womb i mean
this is interesting because if you can
neural net a baby and track its thoughts
in the womb we're going to have a
it'll be a revolution of what a baby is
is it a human is it alive does it have
rights yeah it will at that point
because we're able to communicate with
it but if you can't communicate with it
it doesn't have for all intents and
purposes right i don't know man
sometimes we have difficulty
communicating but i think
i do not understand the logic behind why
a baby at nine months
with with a with a thin layer of flesh
between its face and a per and everyone
else does not have any rights because
it's attached to the mom but the baby
that was born is still attached to the
mom too
well yeah i guess but it's about to be
removed no it's i didn't say they've
decided okay
it's not in the chord no they don't cut
the chord it stays has no rights well
eventually you gotta cut the chord sure
sure but for in that moment it has no
rights i don't know what the process is
could you abort a baby that was born as
long as you don't cut the umbilical cord
god in some places but i don't think
that would be legal i just don't
understand why a baby at nine months
with a fully functioning brain that can
understand music that can kick and moves
around and is literally no different
physically than a baby at the exact same
time of gestation but is outside the
womb they're identical in every way i
don't understand where the separation of
rights has let's let's forget the rights
for a second because i don't like the
rights argument because the left doesn't
believe in the constitution good point
first of all they believe the
constitution is always in flux and our
constitution is amendable in some ways
but they believe in a completely
relativistic view of the constitution
and even claim that the constitution
itself
is illegitimate in its inception due to
slavery the natives and white supremacy
so i don't like the rights discussion
let's just make it more basic
who are the most vulnerable people
in the world
children young children unborn children
babies
what what scenario in a movie
makes us the most angry
when a dog gets hit by a car
yeah
for the liberal for the liberal yuppies
vegan coke hats for sure
but but but for me when i'm watching a
movie the characters that we just that
we despise the most traditionally are
characters that kill a woman who has who
is pregnant or has her children with her
um
you know in some gruesome fashion and
there's a reason for that and people
don't want to give it its proper credit
but abrahamic faith changed the
trajectory from of our society away from
a barbaric child sacrificing culture
that's the story of abraham he goes up
into the mountain and before abraham
child sacrifice was a common practice in
barbaric societies but how else are you
going to get the the grain to grow
that's right
but that's exactly what they're doing
they're sacrificing babies for economic
growth that's their whole argument oh
it's like the resources for them the
harvest what was that what was that
was a book i think i know what you're
talking about yeah they would like the
springtime and then they would like
sacrifice the young woman or whatever
but my point is that the the this this
whole abortion thing
is not about rights and it's not about
republicans and democrats this is an
informational war waged on women
yeah this is a this is a spiritual war
waged on women and to attack men
and the significance of legacy and
lineage
and and and procreation which is one of
the most miraculous gifts that that any
species has human or not but ours is
certainly special given how special
humans have proven themselves to be
scientifically speaking even take away
the faith and the divinity
but this is not about
any of the politics really this is an
attack on women to try and convince
women
that their soul
political power is anchored on their
ability to kill their children
and and there is nothing more
anti-human
anti-american and satanic than to tell
women
all of your political standing should be
dependent on this one
right
to kill
the most important thing and function
you can do as a woman and their argument
is
that the primary function of being a
woman shouldn't be bearing a child
that you know uh
abort if there can be no women's rights
without abortion rights and it's
it's it's it's strange to me that people
don't see how anti-human that really is
is
having a child is
one of the most
amazing things that ever happened to me
i have four but most women say that
about child bearing and and for us to
have reverse psychology convinced an
entire generation of women that their
rights their their political power is
anchored on the right to kill an unborn
child is is completely absurd it's a bit
unfair you know the real issue is that
everyone knows humans die if they don't
have sex like eating them yeah so the
women have no choice they have no choice
but to have sex without protection and
then get pregnant
yeah yeah well right they talk about
they so if they're going to succeed in
the workplace they need to be able to
terminate their pregnancies
or they can you know in all seriousness
just use a condom an iud birth control
or what about what we're saying
why are there many choices why is the
application of science so relative
right because you're never hearing these
arguments about abortion or you know sex
or you know family planning
don't we have reasonable methods to to
measure ovulation we do yep we do i mean
not down to a science there are there
are exceptions but but the ovulation
scheduling is is pretty is pretty
thorough uh and and pretty sure fire in
most cases and that's never even
mentioned that we should use science in
that way they go immediately to let's
kill unborn children now let's use the
advancement of science to to regulate or
track ovulation i've got i've got a
potential hypothesis here
why is it that
the left that is more likely to abort
their kids less likely to even get
pregnant more likely to get vasectomies
more likely to get their tubes tied why
are they so adamant about their being uh
abortion access in red states why are
they so adamant about teaching lgbtq
issues to children
i think these people recognize a very
important thing
they don't have kids
they need republicans to abort their
babies otherwise in 20 years the future
is conservative
if the left is more likely to be lgqt
lgbtqia 2 plus bb or whatever it is
those people are less likely to have
children
if they are already more likely to get
abortions if they do get pregnant all or
more likely to use prophylactics and get
vasectomies they're going to have
substantially less kids
over time conservatives having kids
means this country will be conservative
that's why they need to advocate for red
states to allow abortion so they can try
and stop republicans from having kids
and they can advocate for young
conservative women to don't ruin your
life you you you've got your whole
future out if you have a child later get
the abortion now that was an info award
that the catholic church is somewhat
responsible for too
christianity
this whole child out of wedlock thing i
don't like it you know i'm a christian
i'm a cat i think that the entire
cultural motif of shunning
or or bastardizing
child children that were born out of
wedlock was a predicate for abortion
well so i definitely think that we
should not be shaming pregnancy we
should be shaming adultery adultery was
the part that was wrong they're getting
pregnant part it's not wrong but but
culturally no i hear you i hear humans
made you know that's how you knew if
someone was yes
they looked at the the child born out of
wedlock as another exactly they didn't
they didn't separate the sin of the
parents from the the divinity of the
childbirth very sad and that that that
was a that that that's how you have an
avalanche of cultural decay and
misinformation that ends up being well
you know and even conservatives
christians catholics you know well you
had that child out of wedlock anyway go
ahead and abort the kid that's very safe
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you